so to follow up on what you just said
about you know Hollywood films just
crushing so many independent movies that
being said you're now working on your
fifth feature so you're able to move
through that when a lot of people that
have been in LA for many many years
don't even come close to that
and working with some of the names
you've worked with how is that possible
well I don't think I'm more gifted or
smarter than anyone else I just want to
do it bad enough and this goes back to
what I was saying before I create my own
opportunities I'm not gonna wait for
someone to say oh now we're gonna let
you make this movie I figure out a way
to do it whether and I've always said
this whenever I go into a movie
especially movie like Steel City I said
I'm gonna make this for 30,000 or
300,000 I'm gonna make this movie and I
think once you do that and you create
the sense of urgency and you you're
moving forward people more people start
to hop on but I'm no smarter than it or
more I think there's a lot of passionate
people I hear who passionate about
acting or passionate and who want to do
this and they're convinced this is their
life that's great
but if you're really convinced this is
your life then you have to make it your
life make it a career and I have made
this I made the promise to myself but I
would never give up I will continue
doing it despite whatever setbacks hey
if I've got to go get another day job
you know cleaning carpet or working in a
warehouse I'll do that that's fine but
I'm never going to abandon what I feel
such an essential part of who I am as a
person what I can offer what I you know
I think given a bigger scale getting
given a bigger canvas whether it's
Hollywood and I think you ventually I'm
gonna get there I'll be able to do
something that's going to really affect
you know have me say something to you
know to reach a wide audience but I
don't I'm not entitled that's why I keep
doing these small movies and figuring it
out because you know I really feel that
one day I'll be in a position to reach a
wide audience and when that happens when
they say where did this guy come from
they'll say oh he's been doing all this
stuff he's been working he's been
his craft to get here you know and
that's what I'm doing and I need help
and I need the support of people and I
need crews and great actors and everyone
to come to the thing but I also am
sensitive and I think a lot of people
don't realize this - who come out here
they have to get something out of it -
this isn't the Brian John party and this
isn't the whomever the Bill Jones party
or whatever they got to get something
out of it - whether you write you do
your due diligence and you write a great
script that people that actors are
really gonna like and you raise money to
pay your crew or if you don't have money
to pay your crew you hire people who are
willing to work for certain amount you
know you you have to figure out what
your resources are some people have a
lot of resources some people have no
resources and it's not fair I'm here to
tell you it is not fair some people have
a lot of resource they have a lot of
money they have at their dad's in the
entertainment business there someone's
rich or they give you know it's not fair
this is not a fair game out here it's
just and if people come out here
thinking it's a fair playing field then
they're in for a rude awakening the key
is to figure out what your resources are
what you have access to and to make the
best of it and if you're able to do that
sooner or later I feel like your
resources are gonna grow and the your
outreach are going to grow but if you
spend all your time wallowing in the
fact that you don't have what someone
else has or their outreach or their
their their ability to get more money or
get more exposure that's the way then
you're already dead in the water because
that's the way it's always going to be
period it's not level it's not a fair
playing field out here in LA but any
yeah in LA in particular I think that
applies to life but the entertainment
business it's certainly not a fair
playing field at all I mean you know how
do you explain movie stars kids starring
in movies couldn't they if I'm sure
there's another young actor who's
probably just as good or better but no
you know
it's nepotism it's who you know and and
I think that works for a while until it
doesn't and a lot of deserving people
who work their asses off
do not get opportunities because they're
pushed out of the club because they
don't know enough people but you know
you know I'm under the mentality I'm
gonna fight you know I'm the I'm the guy
that's standing in line waiting for the
guy in the club to who's been there so
long he either he dies or he he goes to
a different club you know unlike a life
you know I you know whatever happens
with me in my life in my career you know
I'm not going away I'm just I'm gonna
keep doing this so going back to Steel
City when you were laying in bed
thinking about it how much obsession you
talked about that obsession I think is
really interesting I mean can you talk
about like how much of your waking time
was spent because so many people have
these great movie ideas myself included
and we don't do anything with them so
what was the difference like you said I
I honestly thought and I was obsessed I
was like I thought I I convinced myself
I was going to die if I didn't make the
movie I thought I was going to get
struck by a fatal disease if I didn't
figure out a way to make the movie that
I would I would he would either happen
now or like I just pictured myself like
laying on my deathbed thinking I didn't
make Steel City I didn't have the guts
and I didn't I didn't do it and I just
told myself I said if this movie kills
me I have to get it made and you know if
I if i bug you know if I have to rob a
bank to get the money to make this movie
I hope I can shoot it before I go to
trial and that's the stipe of stuff I
was thinking like I was obsessed with it
and I think that that can be a turn-off
but when you're young and you're
passionate you can you kind of have some
leeway you can't really on your fifth
film like you know you're not a kid
anymore I mean that you know I'm gonna
turn 35 this year so you have to like be
a little bit more strategic but when
you're young and you know I think you
know I was just
I mean obsess I thought I was gonna lose
my life if I didn't get the film
I mean Syrian it's not an understatement
I thought I finally get the film he
doesn't commit suicide
that's how obsessed I was seriously I
mean
you